[Musique]
les morlaisiens sont au rendez vous pour
fêter les 50 ans de la ville des bribes
de photographies retracent l'histoire de
maurepas sur la plage à cri bout du
chantier de la poste commencé en 1972 à
l'école de la marnière les souvenirs
rejaillissent c'est avec une pointe
d'émotion et beaucoup de fierté que les
maires rigoler galtier outre les
normands temps et que je suis mort
prévient de naissance voilà j'aime ma
ville et voilà je je trouve que son
urbanisme sa conception est une très
bonne chose est une très belle réussite
et en plus de pouvoir accueillir à ce
50e anniversaire l'architecte de
maurepas le fils du promoteur sur hibou
et le sculpteur pour la première fois
réunis ils sont un événement comme celui
là voilà bah c'est un honneur pour moi
tout est pensé pour que chacun fasse
sous un soleil de plomb les enfants
profitent des jouets gonflables
installées pour l'occasion
pendant que les adultes eux échangent
autour d'un repas tout en ostalgie salon
rappelle tous les souvenirs du début
puisque je suis là depuis 1970 69
donc j'ai vu toute l'évolution de des
différents sites qui sont indiqués sur
le sur ces photos quoi moi ça me fait
bizarre parce que j'ai vu mon ancienne
école et
elle a beaucoup changé il y avait des
jeux que je connaissais pas des endroits
où je
tous les jours tout change
il faut ce n'est pas juste comme ça la
journée prend fin et se termine sur une
dernière note de musique
un événement qui sera pour sûr un
souvenir de plus pour les norvégiens
[Musique]